the Joe Rogan experience last show
that's why I'm headbutts like there's
the defense for them you can there is
you can figure it out more he's figured
it out but it's it's perception and
that's what the entire side port has
fought for its entire existence well let
me tell you this cuz I'm beating a dead
horse in this everybody listens this
podcast knows I don't like gloves I
don't think guys should have to wear
gloves
cuz I don't think tell me why you don't
like gloves because I think why should
you have padding on your knuckles that
makes your knuckles more effective when
you don't have it on your shin so you
don't have it on your elbow so you don't
have it on your knees doesn't make any
sense your heel your heel is one of the
hardest on your [ __ ] body
you and everybody seen Terry Adam [ __ ]
that perception how is it okay to shin
somebody in the head this is perception
- it's the reality informed back ok
let's go back I'm going back all the way
to UFC Wayback Machine UFC 8 was the
first time that I ended up in court
before UFC 8 okay because John McCain
had come out with this whole thing and
everyone can sit there and say why John
did it
No oh my thank you very much you hit it
right on the Yser was sponsoring boxing
bingo you know I hear all the stories
the whole know John McCain did us a
favor well you weren't there at that
time he didn't do us any damage they
brought him in because they knew that
they needed someone who was very
respected yep to be against MMA exactly
you got to look at the pay-per-view the
very first pay-per-view for the UFC
87,000 buys they were hoping for a home
run at around 25 they had 87,000 second
one they were in the to hunt they have
180 some thousand then two hundred
thousand and three hundred perspective
today sometimes like what I think who's
a there was a fight for all Mighty Mouse
there was a fight fairly recently or
Mighty Mouse pay-per-view where I think
it only got 150 you know let's be honest
I think probably the last one they had
it's not gonna be up there because there
was so many newness yeah well there's so
much competition running but you had you
know Loma chenko fighting the same night
for free you know and so people look and
go eying you know on this one I can
still watch something and it's not that
that wasn't a good card it's just the
matter of was that the same night as
Bell torrent
seniors bellator so you had all those
things and only one of them you had to
pay for the other right exactly but you
look at all of that man and it's like
it's crazy yeah crazy what happened
because John McCain comes out we go to
court in because Puerto Rico he sends a
letter there and they try to shut it
down we end up in federal court and and
they they bring in this boxing expert to
be on their side and one of the things I
did is you know they had gloves and
they're talking about we had no gloves
and I said you know and I took the glove
and I said here I want to do a
demonstration for you further for the
judge I said I would like that boxing
expert take your hand put it in that
glove now I want you to hit this desk
hit it hard hit it as hard as you can he
goes crack take it off hit it just as
hard now and he goes well I said this is
my point that glove is not there to
protect my head it is there to protect
his hand that is what a glove is for a
glove does not protect someone as far as
their brain scrambling or anything it is
there to protect my hand so I can punch
you more that's what it's there for
100% okay and if you look and say if you
want to take away some things that go
with what's the most traumatic injuries
we have in MMA
people gonna look and say all the stuff
about all we have you know guys breaking
on concussions are the most important
thing that we have going on that's the
most critical thing we have going on and
if someone gets to punch less because
they have to be more precise with where
they're doing it and be careful as far
as how many times they do do it because
they can't continue to do it you know in
that prolonged fashion it doesn't make
it safer or is it more dangerous for the
fighters but it's a perception and it's
you know this goes back to athletic
commissions I think it's crazy has an
MMA in yourself
transcendent wish
[Applause]